[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
noublie rien de rien on n'oublie rien du
tout rien de rien on s'habitue c'est
tout ni ces départs ni ces navires ni
ces voyages qui nous chavirent de
paysage en paysage et de visage en
visage ni tous ces pauves ni tous ces
bars ni tous ces attrapes cafar où l'on
attend le matin gris au cinéma de son
whisky ni tout cela ni rien au monde ne
serura nous faire oublier ne pourra nous
faire oublier pourussi vrai que la terre
est
[Musique]
ronde on n'oublie rien de rien on
n'oublie rien du tout on n'oublie rien
de rien on s'habitue c'est
[Musique]
tout ni c'est jamais ni c'est toujours
ni c'est jet ses amours que l'on
pourçuit à travers cœur de gris en gris
de pleurs en
pleurs ni ses bras blancs d'une seule
nuit collier de Jul pour notre ennemie
que l'on dénoue au petit jours par des
promesses de retour
ni tout cela ni rien au monde ne saura
nous faire oublier ne pourra nous faire
oublier aussi vrai que la terre est
rondee on noublie rien de rien on
n'oublie rien du tout on n'oublie rien
de rien on s'habitue c'est
tout
ni même ce temps où j'aurais fait mil
chansons de mes regrets ni même ce temps
où mes souvenirs prendront mes rides
pour un
sourire et ce grand lit mes remords on
rendez-vous avec la mort ce grand lit
que je souhaite à un jour comme une
fête ni tout cela Ren au monde ne pourra
nous faire oublier ne saura nous faire
oublier au si vrai que la terre est
[Musique]
rondee on noublie rien de rien on
n'oublie rien du tout on n'oublie rien
de rien on s'habitue c'est
tout
merci merci
beaucoup merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup c'était une
chanson bien sûr vous le savez c'était
une chanson qui a été écrite par Jacques
Brell et Gérard Joanis c'est si vous le
voulez bien on va on va partir ensemble
une fois n'est pas coutume